how much state-sponsored
uh cyber attacks are there do you think
more than you can imagine
and it was wait what do you want to say
an attack you had a successful attack or
just a probing probing for information
just like feeling you know testing that
there's where the attack factors are
trying to collect all the possible
attacks put a Windows 7 machine on the
internet forward-facing and put a put a
packet sniffer on there and look at
where the driver comes from I mean been
24 hours you were going to fill up a
hard drive with packets just coming at
it yeah I mean it's it's not hard to to
know I mean it's just constantly probing
for entry points into things you know
you could you could go mad put up
Honeypot draws intrusions should I see
what messages to see what's out there
yeah and it doesn't go anywhere it maybe
has fake information and stuff like that
um you know it's just kind of to see
what's going on and judge what's
happening uh the internet gonna you know
lick your finger and test the wind of
what's happening these days the funny
thing about like because I'm at MIT that
attracted even more attention for the
not for the laws but for the technical
challenge it seems like people enjoy
hacking MIT it's just the amount of
traffic MIT was getting for that in
terms of just the sheer number of
attacks from different places is crazy
yeah like just like that putting up a
machine seeing what comes NASA used to
be the golden ring now everybody got
NASA that was like the early 90s if you
could hack NASA that was the now yeah
MIT is a big one yeah it's fun it's fun
to see
uh respect uh because I think in that
case it comes from a somewhat good place
because you know they're not getting any
money for my ID it's more for the
challenge